ah that crazy comic-con all right so
this is all over the news
or at least websites covering comic-con
if you haven't already heard at
comic-con a guy was stabbed in the face
with a pen while waiting for the
Resident Evil afterlife panel I guess
two guys started arguing because one
felt the other one was sitting too close
to him or some [ __ ] next thing you know
Penn meets face and I love how a lot of
people's first reaction is this clearly
shows one thing comic-con is way too
overcrowded I mean what yeah it's
overcrowded but there's no way this
happened this happened because some
douchebag has anger management issues do
you think it's normal when someone's in
line to be like I can't take the crowd
anymore I'm gonna stab someone and it'll
be their fault yeah it's not Comic Cons
fault it's that guy's fault for being
out of his mind and liking Resident Evil
movies way too much which is probably
his first problem but I think a couple
things in this should be pointed out
first of all this happened during the
Resident Evil afterlife panel but
seriously I mean not the Avengers or the
Capcom Namco panel or anything that
might be worth getting excited about but
Resident Evil afterlife I say fail - the
guy with the pen and I feel it's
important to identify the suspect I'm
not much is known about him except one
thing he's a Harry Potter fan aren't we
all nice going man you're kicked out of
Hogwarts and you're in jail not good I
think it's a Death Eater
I'm calling Death Eater I think the
lesson here is that if you go to
comic-con is strongly recommended that
you wear your plus 26 defense against
ballpoint pens button-up like yours
truly I'm not gonna lie I am all geared
up I don't wear this [ __ ] for fashion
plus 26 pin defense plus 19 charm and
plus 15 intimidate or 47 depending on
the length so all-in-all I've always
heard that comic-con is a really chill
place that I'm sure it is except when
Harry Potter fans go to see the Resident
Evil panel that's when [ __ ] goes down
but I gotta say this incident makes me
really psyched to go to pax because I
had the feeling at PAX if I get stabbed
I'm gonna get stabbed with at least a
proper prop you're like a sword from
Dragon Age or something which would be a
lot better than a pen from Office Depot
and I'm not even gonna ask you guys what
you think of this cuz there's only one
thing to think douche but if all the
things revealed what was your favorite
we'll do that
comment below let me know